uh let's try and dig into the story just
a little bit further and get labour's
perspective on a-levels uh joining us
from sunderland the shadow education
secretary bridget phillips and amos
phillips and lovely to see you this
morning um it is one of those days when
we all start thinking back to getting
our exam results and reminding ourselves
of just how traumatic a day it can be
but
spared a thought for the class of 2022
in the past couple of years that they've
had to go through
absolutely it's it's always a stressful
and worrying time for young people as
they collect their results um but this
cohort of young people in particular
have had a really hard time with it we
know how disruptive kovald has been to
the life chances and opportunities for
our young people
that's why labour set out how we would
do things differently in the support
that they need
to recover from all of that lost
learning and development time and i
think it is appalling
that fewer than one in five have
received any additional catch-up support
out of the government scheme you know we
knew right at the start of the pandemic
that we would need to support our young
people the government completely failed
to put that in place labor set out how
we would do things differently but you
know first and foremost today our young
people have worked really hard and i
just want to congratulate them for
everything that they that they've done
but also their teachers and all the
support staff in schools they've gone
above and beyond to make sure our young
people are supported and they deserve a
big thank you as well
yeah they they certainly do in in terms
of of the way in which the results have
been weighted and of course we know
last year when when teachers were
responsible there was undeniably going
to be a significant amount of
of great inflation was this the right
point at which to sort that out was this
the right year the right cohorts of
students
to have to deal with you know missing
you know perhaps missing out on first
choices certainly not getting the exam
results that they were perhaps predicted
earlier on in the year is that entirely
fair
i think it is right that we do start to
see a return to normality um and from
the many young people that i've spoken
to they did want the opportunity um to
have exams there are problems with
teacher assessed grades as we've seen in
the past and we saw last year and we do
need to avoid that and i'll be looking
carefully when we see more data later
about hopefully we won't this year see
the same disparity that we saw between
private schools and state schools so it
is right that we start to move back but
if we're to do that then we do have to
properly support our young people and
give them all of the help that they need
given the unprecedented nature of the
disruption that they face to their
education that hasn't happened and we
know of course that some young people
have more time out of education than
others because of covert outbreaks and
the government's total failure to put in
place what was needed i do fear will
cast a long shadow
over the life chances of many young
people not simply where it comes to
today and the results that we will be
seeing
right across our economy too because we
know from the work that the government
commissions at kevin collins's work that
this will actually have a big impact on
our economy
where it comes to failure to see wages
increase and tax revenue too that's why
we said it was right to invest in our
children and young people's futures to
put in place a proper recovery plan to
support them and the government's
failure on this i think is a big big
concern
and of course we wish everyone uh
opening a letter or an email today um
all the very best of luck but no doubt
we'll have more to talk about uh in days
to come once we've had the opportunity
to go through the to go through the data
i do want to ask you though of course
we're just about to start a weekend of
disruption
in terms of the rail bus and indeed the
troops
network a few minutes ago i spoke to the
rmt's mick lynch i just wonder if i can
just play you and our viewers at what he
said and we'll come back to you in just
one second
only the cuc can call a general strike
what we're seeing across the country i
address to meeting thousands of people
last night i dressed a massive one in
glasgow on tuesday there is a wave of
reaction
uh amongst working people to the way
they're being treated people are getting
poorer every day of the week people
can't pay their bills they're getting
treated despicably in the workplace i
think there will be generalized and
synchronized action it may not be in a
traditional form but we've seen the the
post office workers and bt
we've seen the bus workers in london out
on strike tomorrow and over the weekend
i think there is a massive response
coming from working people because
they're fed up with the way they're
being treated
mr lynch responding there to a question
i i posed to him about the possibility
of there being a general strike he
deferred decisions on that of course to
to the tuc but from what he was saying
and from what you and i can see you know
reading the newspapers and looking at
our windows there is an awful lot of dis
factor satisfaction there is going to be
an awful lot of industrial action
do you feel that we might well be
heading in the direction of a general
strike
well i sincerely hope not but of course
it is within the gift of the government
to try and sort this out but you know
we've got real strikes today and we have
a secretary of state who hasn't lifted a
finger to do anything about it who
hasn't taken the responsible and
sensible approach in seeking to get a
compromise i mean why you have strikes
that's because you failed to
get a compromise that you can all live
with and of course you know working
people are facing massive pressure right
now on their living standards that's why
labour has said
we would make sure that energy bills are
frozen and we pay for that through a
windfall tax on oil and gas producers
and when i speak to people both here in
sunderland and right across the country
you know you're confronted with parents
who are telling me that they're skipping
meals in order to make sure that
children don't go without pensioners who
had turned off their heating months ago
because they're so worried about how
they're going to pay the bills so in
that context i do understand how
frustrated many workers are that they've
got a government that isn't prepared to
support them whether that comes to
energy bills or where it comes to
actually seeking to get a compromise on
p and we've seen that both right across
many areas of our public sector whether
that's schools as well as real
but also in the private sector too where
people are finding it really really
tough at the moment
sure but but surely this it is somewhat
paradoxical that a time in which you
quite rightly say so many people
particularly those most disadvantaged
are having a really really tough time of
it at the moment the labour party lost
nearly 100 000 of its members last year
and ended they ended the 12 months 5
million pounds in the red i mean what
does it say if we are seeing industrial
unrest on a scale such as this if we are
seeing poverty on the scale that we are
that people are leaving rather than
flocking to the labor party
we will always see fluctuations in our
membership but labor was not true
at different points in the cycle but
labour as a party was founded to
represent the interests of working
people across our country that's what
we're about that's why i joined the
labour party to make sure we see a
fairer society and better life chances
both for our young people that we're
talking about today but workers too
we're on a much stronger and more
sustainable flooding now as a party
we're looking outwards to the country um
we're ready to give britain the fresh
start that it needs under kiev's star i
think if you look at the current
government however although frankly it
often feels like we don't have a
government they're not able to take any
kind of big decision decisions there are
zombie government arguing amongst
themselves not looking outwards the
labour party we are looking outwards to
the country about the challenges we face
putting forward practical solutions like
freezing energy bills to give people the
help okay
you're talking you're talking a good
game there but you're losing a hundred
thousand members at a time of you know
almost unprecedented industrial risk
unrest does speak to you know problems
within the party some might suggest the
somewhat confusing lines being taken by
the labour party as regards the strike
as regards being on the picket line i
mean would you constant standing next to
mick lynch on an rmt picket
well i'll not be on a picket line today
because i'll be off visiting a school in
the northeast uh this morning to meet
with our young people getting their
results but you know i want to be a part
of the next labour government and if we
are to be that next government then we'd
be you know sat around the table seeking
to get a solution to all of this so we'd
be involved in trying to get an
agreement get people around the table
you look at the current government
they're not interested in that they just
want to stalk that division cause
problems and actually see the strikes
continue it feels to me like they
desperately want those strikes to go
ahead i don't want strikes to happen i
mean they represent a fairly when you
get to that point workers know that
trade unions know that they would always
want to get a compromise but you've got
a government that's completely unwilling
to listen
and is not able to take decisions at the
moment so it's a little wonder that
workers are really really fed up when
they've got these massive gas and
electricity bills falling on the map
where they face an unprecedented squeeze
on their wages over these last 12 years
of conservative governments because it's
not just the recent months of course
there's additional pressures you know
many of our staff whether that's in
schools
or in the nhs have had a massive squeeze
on their wages over that time and
they're working harder than ever they
deserve a government on their side labor
will always make sure we properly
support the people that on whom we
depend we praise them during the
pandemic we clap for them and now the
government's just totally abandoned them
at bridget phillips and great to me on
the program as always thanks for joining
us
thank you